est correct comme ça le langage non j'en
ris voilà ce que met de l'avant le
gouvernement fédéral dans son nouveau
guide sur l'écriture inclusive il s'agit
d'un outil pour la fonction publique et
non d'un guide rigide ou de règlement à
suivre obligatoirement au final c'est
les personnes qui utilisent les outils
qui vont choisir les options parmi
l'éventail qui leur est proposé des
pronoms comme yels sont suggérés pour
remplacer soit le il ou le l le
gouvernement recommande aussi l'usage de
mono genré par exemple le mot
parlementaire au lieu de députés qui lui
peut prendre un e ou non à la fin selon
le genre c'est des efforts qui va à la
peine d'être faits que la diversité de
genre soit partie intégrante de la
langue française c'est logique selon
cette intervenante c'est une question
d'inclusivité et d'ouverture d'esprit
elle aimerait d'ailleurs que les lignes
directrices deviennent éventuellement
obligatoires d'avoir une ressource comme
ça qui vient d'une autorité au fédérale
je pense que ça va permettre à beaucoup
d'être adressé comme il se la thèse de
doctorat de Nikita camelet Bengal porte
sur la place de l'écriture inclusive
dans les médias elle aimerait d'ailleurs
que les suggestions ne se limitent pas
qu'à la fonction publique qu'elle soit
étendue à la population en général on a
intégré tellement de nouveaux mots dans
la langue française et je vois pas
pourquoi on ne pourrait pas intégrer ces
nouvelles techniques aussi c'est selon
moi c'est la même chose ces nouvelles
lignes directrices sont toutefois loin
de faire l'unanimité je ne vois pas
pourquoi il faudrait étendre à
l'ensemble de la population des règles
qui ne concernent qu'une minorité cet
écrivaine estime d'ailleurs que
l'application concrète des directives
pose un réel défi faut veiller à ce que
la langue ne soit pas du coup comment
dire perte de sa saveur lequel ne soit
pas complètement aseptisé par ce langage
qui introduit une distance trop souvent
entre le message et ceux qui le
reçoivent il existait déjà des lignes
directrices sur le langage inclusif en
anglais plusieurs demandes avaient été
formulées pour qu'un tel document de
référence en français soit collaboré le
Bureau de la traduction qu'on offrir des
séances d'information pour aider les
fonctionnaires à ce familiariser avec
les nouvelles recommandations ici
Rebecca coine Radio-Canada
Ottawa